the Joe Rogan experience you see Oprah
fall down yes and it's honestly she's a
little old to be falling down I loved I
loved it Wow loved it she get hurt
people get hurt he's fine he's dead
she died yes all right ding dong the
witch is dead now she did and she died
your honor he ever [ __ ] no she didn't
no she's fine I just think like she
looks like she got hurt it's nice to see
billionaires fall oh how about that
that's weird
it's nice to see somebody hit no it
humanizes her she is such a figure of
perfection women should learn do those
[ __ ] shiny bottom shoes then [ __ ] is
a useless yeah those things they're so
slippery
those those really expensive shoes the
gals like you always have the the shiny
bottoms yeah here she is walking and I
believe she's talking about balance
which is lol the irony is staggering so
flat ground Oh spicy dust let's see how
she recovers she says new shoes oh those
rude [ __ ] hits the ground over and over
again well you know what I gotta say I
like how she framed with her elbow and
then did a roll she absorbed a lot of
energy and a roll
good technique oh not bad watch this
here we go 3 little bit on the left hip
that shit's probably sore but one thing
you gotta say about Oprah she works out
a lot and she has she's got muscles she
went and ran a marathon recently thanks
to marathon in six hours which is not
the best time she still ran 26 [ __ ]
miles in a day don't you think it's nice
to see people fall it's humbling to
watch someone like that I just think
what did she really
that's an hour faster than Bert Christ
it's about that's that I could do it I
mean I did run it ran it four and a-five
for 29 how fast is that like a mile 10
17 that's really good mmm that's a good
clip wait a minute
she's doing better than you [ __ ] no way
that's right imagine you and Oprah in a
race she dusts you ten minute miles yes
26 of them [ __ ] so that's what six
miles an hour about whoo yeah let me
tell you
I'm scared let me tell you something a
little nervous right 1994 though that
was four years old
oh no she ran one recently though okay
yeah I just typed in okay that's not
very good though when she was 40 which
makes me cry on speed back then yeah and
steroid quaaludes everything no I just
think it's it's humbling to watch
someone so beloved take a little stupid
spill it's just kind of like yeah that's
the balance of the universe was not
perfect to everybody
mmm nice to watch perfect people fall a
little bit that's fun that understand it
makes she's a part of the people now
especially if she's like new shoes you
know how this goes it's fun you know
yeah well it's slippers shoes man that's
not what it was like yes it is she's
getting older that was I'm getting older
fall Oh watch it again that was like I'm
lost my balance from I'm just getting
older but it's so stupid shoes I can't
find our recent one there you go she
didn't really know the story has gone on
around recently but only five years ago
unless I'm or something I swore there
was one that they were referencing a
year before like she ran it for a late
birthday she ran one of the marathons
for like her fifties something.if
birthday 60th she's in her 60s right I
feel like her 60th birthday or something
like that she wouldn't never run a
marathon though never you'll never catch
me it's almost scary no I left run I run
and I run almost every day but I'm never
gonna run a marathon why because I don't
need to it's an insane amount of
distance no defensive he is out of
nowhere like someone's grilling I can
eat how about this house there's it it
died I mean yes right good boy
how about this campaigns runs one a day
yeah camp come on does I know but it's
like enough we get it no that's too much
you don't do too much you just his knees
are gonna [ __ ] fall off his body
great right now they're gonna fall over
than you it's good send me your knees
cam send me your cartilage or your lack
thereof
[Applause]